siamo nel menu dovete stare calmi siamo
nel menu ti ammazzo non ho mai visto è
sono io questo no vabbè ma non ho mai
visto meno così fico siamo ragazzi suoi
mini posti play due sono le 5 del
mattino ragazzi di giorno non ho mai
visto un menù così figo va bene nuova
partita diciamo che era una vita che
aspettavamo tutti quanti il gioco
ufficiale ho pagato anche 8 euro va giù
ok
avevo cercato già la demo di questo
gioco quindi questa farsa in cui l'avevo
già faccia con trovare chiavi della
macchina sta parte con me la ricordo
uguale alla demo
il problema è che non sono riuscito a
finire la sta partendo almeno adesso o
quasi la foresta
porca vacca sono miglior dono spenta io
ciao
ma c'è di tutto
roma non devo fare più cose va bene ed
io non ti preoccupare non uscire burke
hare tanto mi piace satana in casa una
donna senza gente che corre ovunque non
capisco perché mi dava una torcia da
qualche parte viste una torcia esisterà
una torcia 8 euro pagato sul gioco un
banco cialente messa la doccia non c'è
più il bambino bambino
sega ha detto porca vacca morta ma
marche di sodio dove messori che avete
posso andare di sopra senza che nessuno
mi mangi la faccia chiavi eccole no
questo è un cavatappi vi uccido col
cavatappi eccole le chiavi della
macchina parka vacca perfetta vai vai
vai veloce via via via via via via via
via poi spento devo lavare i piatti
prima di andare ma tu sei stupido ma
queste scelte ha dei problemi ma guarda
che merda questi piatti sono un incubo
ma non li vedo neanche diavolo stai a
presto
stai giocando a cricket sono baci su no
no no io vi ammazzo futuro no ragazzi
faccio male
no no no non esiste dei temi anche la
demo era così come uscire da questa
maledetta casa a prendere le chiavi
ok ragazzi stavolta un meccanismo di
autodifesa abbastanza efficiente
rispetto a prima ma le chiavi sono fermi
tutti zitti che devo capi come arriva
all uscita quella e l'uscita con le sole
chiavi aiop io le chiavi e corro veloce
però c'è perché dovrei andarmene perché
sei stupido
sono uscito o no sono ci sono uscito
[Musica]
allora basta perché mi sporca di una
vacca o lasciare la torcia qui
salve gesù in terra ma raga ma io posso
uscire di qua ma è aperto non c'è più è
sparita eccola lì non è servito a niente
però ok contiamo a prenderci jumps kerr
c'è una macchina qualcuno mi sta
investendo dopo che avuto già voglio
sapere dov'è che andrò a consegnare
seguici stanotte a è cambiata è cambiata
ok a sé mandati via che bello pasti
sempre allegri tra l'altro invece di
uscire è la mamma please take my eyes
and with your love my mamma bassa
inerzia
segue matt botta fuck you to you e se va
bene però che non sto capendo se non lo
vuoi semplice loro magno io ah ok
perfetto va no c'è la satana là dentro
che c'era anche in casa mia ma vabbè lo
smoking tranquillo tanto non credo che
sia il pericolo più grande è qua dentro
che bello c'è una nuova zona non avevo
ancora scoperta l'ha mica quanto grosso
sto passo e guarda un martello potresti
usarlo per difenderti ma facciamo che no
va bene senza che è successo
controlliamo facebook che fioretta great
a queste il piede di greta vale non lo
sapevo grazie della carmela di
governance occhi rimossi prima del fuoco
una bambola trovata e asce non sono così
bravo in inglese
questo lo so tradurre mister tasters
salve ma ora congelate strano come
chiedere non è che chi fa i versi
orlando questo livello 1 e intanto si
sono fatte la dottoressa sia sera perché
non mangi seguici alle 7 del mattino a
meno che non fai schifo vi prendete il
mio fottutissimo sanguisughe razzi e poi
ve ne me ne vado via presunta era chiudi
ti chiudi ti chiudi ti prego non ti ho
fatto niente io non sono tua madre non
lo le tette
vai via cosa sta succedendo in questo
gioco è andato via davvero ma ormai a
furia di giocargli horror ciò la skill
ciò la steel non so io ti giuro sono tuo
amico non mi fare niente
casino porca eva morta che bordello lo
puoi provare ad aprirla in silenzio
perché fai casa nokia la delicatezza di
un elefante ma dove possono andare di
qua no no no raga ciao fastidio vai vai
frate vai devo seguire cerca di non
toccarlo ma vai zio vai zio sinistra la
mamma sinistra la mamma ea sinistra
sinistra
taci sua ma sarà da eccola qui li
mortacci sua quanto tempo pensa tessera
ok ora se tutto va bene arrivo fino al
punto della tessera se riesco teli a
sinistra e gli zii avviene zio frate o
contesta parla ok perfetto sinistra
bailly vai bravo esatto cesto scatola
norme come lo tocco mi uccide quello
e invece no è sordo meno male devo basta
che non corro se non corro tutto a posto
bene next porta anni per sole novi nel
mentre c'è chi vuole nora per arrivare a
questa parte
ragazzi facciamo che concludo questa
pagina perché sta succedendo cose quindi
va bene così per ora sto contento sono
soddisfatto di essere riuscito arrivare
finalmente un punto decente fatemi
sapere se volete continuo nel mentre con
più che ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come al solito se video è
piaciuto sono commento mi piace anche
vari social cominciato nel schizzi e
iscrivetevi sono state prestiti a noi ci
crediamo
l'anno prossimo da ragazzi
[Musica]